vous avez environ quatre Humvees, vous êtes clair sur
ce qui semble
être un hélicoptère militaire américain tirant sur
des journalistes non armés 12 millions de personnes ont
vu cette vidéo vous voulez toujours me dire
que vous pensez que ce n'est qu'un petit site Web,
ils ont une vérité sur l'agenda  justice l'
homme American Way est le moins lui-même quand
il parle en sa propre personne mais si vous
lui donnez un masque il vous dira la
vérité deux personnes et un secret le
début de toute conspiration plus de personnes
et plus de secrets mais si on pouvait trouver
une morale  homme un dénonciateur quelqu'un
prêt à révéler ces secrets que l'homme
pourrait renverser les régimes les plus puissants et les plus
répressifs
cette banque cache des milliards de dollars
dans des comptes offshore nous allons clouer
ces [ __ ] l'ancien chef de la
plus grande banque d'Islande a été accusé de fraude
nous  a démantelé une banque d'un milliard de dollars
c'est un
courage fou est contagieux la Maison Blanche a
fustigé aujourd'hui la fuite de plus de 90 000
documents militaires les journaux militaires
exposés h  des centaines d'informateurs là-bas nos
vies sont plus risquées j'ai besoin des noms de
sources qui pourraient être blessées si ces
câbles sont diffusés ils viennent après
nous nous devons publier maintenant c'est la
plus grande fuite d'informations classifiées
de l'histoire
The Guardian New York Times tous  se tenir à
vos côtés cela va
tout changer ce n'est pas un journaliste c'est une
menace pour la sécurité nationale c'est
une question de survie comme un état désolé qu'en est-
il de la vie des civils dans
ces conflits s'ils avaient eu quelqu'un comme
vous les garçons de Berlin seraient descendus
oui  avant que nous soyons au bord d'une
crise internationale majeure si vous voulez faire
cela, vous devez le faire maintenant c'est juste vous
et votre ego si les mensonges que vous racontez pour obtenir
ce que vous voulez c'est une information dont
le monde a besoin de savoir dont vous avez besoin  pour
écraser ces mecs slide
tu veux la vérité tu devrais la
chercher par toi même c'est ce qu'ils ont
peur de toi